hello guys Greg Alva here so don't go
crazy on instagrams me we're going to
give you another stoner reaction to what
I call our videos Tony I mean everyone
constantly thinks that we're smoking
yeah right before and sometimes we are
we're we today did we just take eye
drops
who knows I'll take my eyes I've ever
been this way
no no that's because of the superb
skills of the drops spider-man
homecoming weird trailer by Aldo Jones
oh yes another one got a lot of red
wonder this
[Music]
Oh God wait a minute
the real Avengers I can tell hope gives
it away look like a real fake probably
stop Sidda she'll become an Avenger
cutter that's why we'll take any
disciplinary would do and definitely go
to everything education great great area
and that's where you all right just want
a hug the Grammys okay oh yeah
[Music]
[Music]
here's a swing these rivers oh forget
the flying monster day there people
[Music]
[Music]
anyway comment hi Ron
[Music]
hello my darling evening thank you for
harmonic with trader if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel like it
and share it on your social networks
let's go on with the celebration of the
previous will trailer superhero we post
contest winner is an Italian guy and his
name
definitely this is each speaker try to
find the curative illegal weapons in
this trader which video carefully and
try to find the caption tautomer
and the Batman pattern if you will find
the three weasels please leave a comment
so when you say determine the position
so if you will be the first one to get
the weakened position and we're instance
you'd be true in next we trigger what it
does one so I expect me in the previous
week trader the passengers with trainer
it was a little difficult to find Waldo
so here it is okay let's apologize with
using a time very simple with basic
suitable please send me a picture this
email with your windy space the weirdest
ones will be inserted in next with
trader the winner of this month our big
guys send information for share locks
result for its first appearance on the
big screen perseverance you so much
Dobby please consider the support my
channel by patreon which greatest need a
lot of time and a lot of work so
donation are especial to make this
format wrong you can unique potential
you can unit my favorite is the query
with a holder for you the pants is a
constellation of I'll be speaking you
can support my channel sponsor you also
and order it ok but if you donate at
least $5 or more you can be deadly be
doubly sure in the next 3 trailer like
this if well view our video to make a me
McVicker reaction or other stuff you can
do it there is no problem but the
important thing is that you create me
how has the link to the original video
please don't upload this video on your
social accounts approve rebooting and
is not good for theaters if you want to
be active in video you can do it but
please use this video in a little window
not full screen like this give me what I
want tragically to subscribe because
reactions can but they are really really
really what about me I want to thank so
much all myself what about a man Python
fellows you could include in this area
thank you so much leaving why do you not
have left me a beer but a betrayer
it is because I am racist we gotta give
it up suddenly gave me that one and uh
which one was it uh I want to eat
everyone's range where you're like right
behind a life that doesn't matter if
he's done it before alga my Italian
brother I'm half Italian man you're my
Italian relative Mountain now we know we
could jump on that patreon I saw up I
don't want to that money man
oh I give him money I first thought like
before I ever saw his face that he was
like a young black guy okay and then
because that's not a thumbnail or
something represented and then actually
his face and I was like oh he's one of
those like hey I'm a computer okay yeah
I di or something I don't up and then he
talks he's Italian yep going for the
mystery of Aldo Jones has been solved
he's just sexy hairy Italian Hong man
and you know kind of split them trail is
he knows how to split them trails oh
yeah man as a fighter man party was the
best one I just love the thousands of
Peter Parker's dancing the streets a lot
of that in here I mean they definitely
throw as much as they can in these
trailers but a day lucky key maybe
someone else now he doesn't work with
anybody else although that's what well
that's the Italian way some of the
things actually look like it was split
together really good like it actually
has like even when my dad was dancing at
the beginning when his arm got ripped
off I was like a fatality oh yeah this
is bloodiest weird trailer that you've
done are you gonna look for the no you
don't want you know look for it he said
only the ones who find it for
first one to call oh [ __ ] if it doesn't
mean that's going to solidify my chances
what we could do is submit weird faces
for him right do your weirdest
facetiming go for it
there you go although you did it again
and I'm done
subscribe to Aldo Jones subscribe to the
real rejects check out trees the
audience the gram here it is goodbye big
look out of focus we are let's you come
this close oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
looks that oh yeah that's great
it looks great bit that's funny stick
you down in the wall a man so tired
honey let's just go to sleep come on
come on
I'll ask my hunky man Leo 15 million
from this position and they I'm losing
going like this each time